hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast i am brett weinstein your host
and i am pleased to be sitting here with
mike naina documentary filmmaker
extraordinaire welcome Mike thank you
pretty good and pretty good let's start
by recognizing that you don't sound like
you're from around these parts no I'm
from Melbourne Australia Melbourne
Australia that seems really far away it
is and yet your language is so intuitive
something so what brings you to the US
many things I think that opportunities
in the film and television industry at
home dried up and a project in
particular took me over here so I was
working on a documentary about the
grievant Studies affair
it's Peter Boghossian James Lindsay and
Helen Black Rose were submitting hoax
articles to academic journals to test
the political biases of certain academic
fields and I got tangled up in that
project with with them before they
started writing so I've been filming the
process all the way through so I've been
going back and forth between Australia
and here for I'd say near on two years
now when's the first time we met it was
at the James to more event it's very
early
was it the James to more event yeah so I
met you through Peter I also met James
and Helen through Peter and so we met at
the d'amour event and then I think the
next time we met would have been maybe
you guys came over to our place yeah
yeah yeah yeah it would have been that
and so just to catch people up you were
working on the grievance studies affair
mm-hmm and you were documenting it as it
unfolded yeah and at some level the
evergreen affair was tangential to that
yes it was happening locally because we
knew Peter and so you looked into it to
be kind of a I don't know a side light
or an added dimension
yeah the what you were working on yeah
and at the point that you started
looking into
the Evergreen situation it becomes
difficult to turn it into a small
snapshot very much so yeah there's so
much depth to it so the gravity of the
Evergreen story you kind of get you get
drawn into it and you're like holy crap
what is what has actually happened to
you yeah it's a modern-day witch burning
really it's it's it's and as you know
not even figuratively yeah people who
orchestrated it much to my amazement I
did not know this at the time but the
people who orchestrated it viewed it as
a justified witch hunt yeah that because
I was white and male and yes straight
that I was deserving of being which
haunted yeah in order to give me the
same experience that others have had
well your image became an effigy which
they then but repeatedly here all right
so um so you came to the Evergreen
affair at the point that you realized
that it was its own story and you made
what I regard as an absolutely beautiful
three-part documentary which people can
find I will link it in the description
and that documentary is a number of
different things I mean I must say it's
personally very meaningful to me at a
number of different levels there's a way
in which it solved a problem that was
inherent to where Heather and I had
landed and the problem was that our
predicament was almost impossible to
fathom from any mmm normal position
because it was so odd and that created a
kind of alienation
because interacting with other people
they would say old can you explain you
know what happened at Evergreen just
briefly and it was like no no yeah yeah
yeah what's more even if one attempts to
describe it at length describing it
doesn't quite cut it no so Benjamin
Voice had done a lot of work necessary
for people to understand what happened
he unearthed a tremendous amount of
stuff and without a lot of it and very
interesting former Jerseyans ooh gruel
to my film as well right and then you
you picked up a lot of what he had
unearthed yeah and you put it in
very cinematic form yeah
and anyway the the net outgrowth of that
was the things I thought nobody was ever
really going to understand and not what
happened at Evergreen things that I
remember even in real time sitting there
the canoe meeting for example yeah
sitting in the canoe meeting one of my
thoughts was what is going on here is
jaw-dropping hmm there's no way to
convey what has happened yeah to
outsiders and your films they solved
that problem as they did convey it yeah
and so that was a big weight off my
shoulders well that particular piece of
footage was the reason why I sought you
out because so we'd met and not only
loosely heard about the Evergreen the
events at Evergreen and then after
meeting you I went and did some homework
and read the Washington Examiner piece
that you guys had and it linked to that
piece of footage and it was a moment of
because I was working on the grievant
study stuff and I was quite a few months
in reading the scholarly Canon I guess
and the the major texts around that and
what was looking to me like was some
some kind of victimhood theology so I
was calling it because the the peer
review comments that the guys were
getting back for the fake papers that
were writing but very it was paying
lip-service to the scientific method and
and rigor but it was really what it was
policing was some kind of it was like a
a set of moral rules and they were cut
and I was slowly figuring out what this
was which because it wasn't it's not
science they were they were trying to
sort out here it was some kind of
intuitive moral system that were
creating and so it's it really did start
looking like some kind of theology to me
it was it was very young like a
prescriptive sociology that was based on
moral intuitions and I was like well how
do I convey that because it's all paper
and it's all words and comments and
things like that and it took me a long
time to figure out that this is
potentially what's going on here and
then I saw that footage and I was like
this is a service this is the this what
I
I'm seeing in there scholarship and the
major texts are there working is he this
is this is like the it's the natural
progression of what I imagine a theology
would would create so you mean when you
say this is a service you mean this is a
religious service you're not saying
they've done us a service by provider
it's funny because I had the OP had the
other reaction while I was sitting yeah
because you know they set this thing up
they strongly encouraged us to go to
this media and when I got there they had
you know they have these very fancy
television cameras they have a TV studio
that they outfitted and it's always been
a complaint amongst faculty that was
underutilized right and the bridges
administration started using these
cameras they filmed everything and thank
for that but anyway I walk in there and
these cameras are set up right and I
begin to realize how how they view what
they're doing yeah and then as the thing
unfolds you know it's been billed as a
forum to discuss the plan but yeah no
room to discuss anything other than the
goodness of its objectives
yes utopian view of things and as I'm
sitting there I'm thinking okay nobody
is ever gonna understand this I can't
explain it it's gonna be hard enough to
explain to Heather and she knew that the
movie was coming and in fact she said
you have to go to this yeah right now
she wasn't going to things but I was
going religiously as it were to
everything because there was so much
going on but I I guess maybe I hadn't
even realized that there was a meeting
he's like no no no you gotta go but I
wasn't gonna be able to explain it yeah
her because it was so far beyond yeah
the most extreme thing I had yet seen it
seen at that point and then as I'm
sitting there I'm thinking they're
filming this yeah and then I thought
there's no way that they are dumb enough
to allow that footage out and so I was
trying to figure out can I force them to
release it before they delete it which
any reasonable person who had done what
they were doing would have done
because that footage is very clear right
how far around the bend this movement
was for us no for them
exactly so anyway to somewhere there's
an email in which I emailed them after
the event it's like I do think the
entire community not everybody was
present I do think the entire community
needs to see the footage of that meeting
when can we expect it yeah trying to
prompt them yeah but they were proud of
it and they put it out much to my
surprise and and you made excellent use
of it it is an interesting thing at the
heart of the Evergreen moral panic I was
that how proud everyone was there was a
lot of footage of that it's this huge
from my perspective this huge
sociological event like it was really
the case study for this this way of
thinking and the fact that everyone was
so proud to put up did they filmed
everything in pride they filmed it
because they were proud of it and I'm
seeing all these horrific things from my
position outside of that moral community
going what the hell is going on here why
would you be proud of that and so the
series was just kind of an accidental
series I kind of stumbled into it is
more or less just that really it's you
and my perspective of the stuff that
they're probably still proud of they're
still doubling down on this way of
thinking still yeah even like as of this
week they are so W loved to sit down and
watch that series next to like George or
Naima and saw some questions I really
want to hang out with these guys I agree
I think this is it may or may not be
possible because they they did figure
out one thing right away which was that
every time they touched media outside of
their little bubble it did not play well
you can't get him you can't get anyone
like the amount of people I've tried to
reach out to and talk about this stuff
as soon as they get a hint I mean it's a
hostile media environment so you can
kind of like for everyone so if someone
wants to put a camera on you you're
looking for a friendly but but Eve even
so you know look I know you I know me
yeah the fact is I would give him a fair
shot and I think you know as
as we've talked about repeatedly there
are a lot of these concepts that have
something true in yeah somewhere yeah
right and then they've been distorted so
grotesquely and they become you know the
basis for a witch-hunt yeah there is a
lot to talk about and so anyway it would
be fascinating if they would interact
but they have this litmus test either
you will sign up for these things when
yes so far beyond the pale that no
reasonable person will yeah or we won't
talk to you hmm
and that's just simply where where it
stands but you're right
their pride and their it's not just
pride their certitude that what they are
doing is still correct they've learned
the only thing they've learned is not to
talk to people it will record them yeah
but I would say I see no evidence of any
other learning of any kind and that is
maybe the greatest tragedy well it's the
it's the blinkers Hyde says morality
binds and blinds and so from the
religious stance I'm using it as a
descriptive tool this religious way of
looking at it and I think it's the most
powerful one to understand what the
hell's going on there but from a calm
you
a religion is a moral community that's
gathered around a group of stories and
scriptures and so I started looking at
the stories and scriptures and trying to
figure that out and then to better
understand the moral community but they
they can't see outside of it that's why
all these crazy stuff is happening
because inside the bubble it makes sense
but as soon as you're outside of it it's
clown world
it's clown world and it is also you know
what Heather and I spent a year saying
in the aftermath of this was that
evergreen was really set up to serve
underserved communities mmm it was the
college for people who were not a good
fit for other places and a lot of the
people who were not a good fit for other
places were people from you know racial
backgrounds that were disadvantaged or
had some other unusual feature to their
story and they really needed faculty to
deal with them as individuals which
evergreen the structure of it made
possible
so what is very hard for us to get past
is that evergreen was not highly
functional at the point it came apart
but it was still functional and it could
easily have been fixed mmm
what they did instead was they destroyed
the functional part which was
well-suited to serve people who are
usually underserved and replaced it with
a myth that is incapable of serving
anybody and in fact it it does the
opposite it leads them to believe that
there is some sort of help to be had
from you know from wallowing in victim
mmm-hmm which frankly isn't going to
work it's the saddest part about this I
think it's all about empowering
communities I've couldn't you couldn't
disempower community more by getting
them to build their I'd entered entity
around their victimhood
which is this sacred totem that they
have to build their identity around
victimhood and to reject the very tools
that would empower them most and that
are the antidote to bias and they're
everyone's tools like I mean they've got
the whole its masters tools don't don't
touch the Masters tools will never
dismantle the Masters house house but
they're your [ __ ] tools like they're
everyone's tools and humanity has taken
a long time to get to these tools
they're like the most beautiful thing
that anyone can pick up I gotta tell you
the master has the best tool his quality
stuff and if you want to take down his
house that's the place to find the stuff
with the power to do it yeah and so you
know I do want to say I'm certain that
Audrey Lord meant something by that
quote that you know I probably would
argue with it even at in the way that
she meant it yeah the way that it is
utilized is absolutely self destructive
and you know science this is
counter-intuitive - we've used science
as this very powerful paradigm it is
very powerful
the reason it's powerful is that it
corrects for bias that human beings have
a confirmation bias problem and science
is the thing that allows us to see past
it and so to the extent that one
believes civilization is biased against
people the tool you that you want to
hone is scientific and so to attack
science
to entak enlightenment values to attack
the idea of merit and then substitute in
this religious view of who is deserving
on the basis of what characteristics
that they walked through the door with
is just it's it's the most ironic
self-sabotage imaginable but there is
this sense that this is very much like
the original post modernist akule I like
them and so they get a lot of flack for
what's going on but deep inside it is
this sense that I'm so deep deep inside
the Foucauldian view is that that there
is science right but there's also the
branding of science so science gets kind
of used it used as weapons for
absolutely powerful yep and so you
what's happened with this next iteration
is they're going for actually the
beautiful thing in the middle instead of
the surrounding uses of science so if we
kind of laid down the the blueprint of
how knowledge works and our power works
through that knowledge and they have
adopted that to create their own version
of the worst part of that does that make
sense to you and so it is working in so
far as that blueprint is true like I
think that they're really they're really
these these applied post modernist these
people who came through the 90s they're
trying to take over our systems of
knowledge production and it's hitting up
against reality and scientists because
it's only true in certain aspects like
it's in the promotional kind of this big
marketing campaign that they're they're
creating well they also don't appreciate
and I think almost nobody appreciates
how much stuff is functioning that
depends yet on this other worldview and
so if you're very focused on what
doesn't work in your world because you
know let's say you're black in the u.s.
black in the US is a problem does it
mean there are no successful blacks no
but it is a problem right it's a it's a
predicament that has a long history
that nobody alive today had anything to
do with building but if you're focused
on that problem and your point is well
if we swap out the thing that empowered
those who did this then we'll be good
you don't realize that the electric grid
nuclear reactors the thing that keeps us
from being attacked by foreign powers
all of this is actually built on a
scientific framework has that framework
been misused regularly and you should
expect it to continue to be yes used
yeah right what we want to do is
minimize the level at which it's misused
but you you can't prevent it but when
somebody like me a scientist says no the
scientific method is about preventing
bias we're talking about the method
we're not talking about those who wear a
lab coat are speaking the truth yeah
right that's preposterous not scientific
yeah so anyway see that that conception
of the person the labs that coat
speaking the truth and him being full of
[ __ ] that is inside their their way of
thinking and so they put on a lab coat
they put the PS their PhD badge on and
then they they speak so confidently like
they speak so confidently about things
they shouldn't be confident about
because in their worldview everyone else
is speaking like that
and unfortunately the scientific
establishment has allowed some really
low quality stuff to be sanctioned yeah
mundane economic reasons that have to do
with the way universities are funded and
all of that but well many ways the life
right like it's just nothing's perfect
you're gonna have some issues well it
could attack those issues I think it
could be a lot better yeah we could have
yet we could we could declare a border
between the market and science and we
could protect science as the important
thing that it is we should do that yeah
having not done that there is a lot of
garbage east up gets dressed up in
scientific clothing and so it's not as
if there's no point to be made yeah but
no I
if your point is there is no science
it's all about powers well
hang on guys yeah that one that's the
thing like fucose like they're there
Jesus but he talks about these stuff
yeah he says that um that there is such
things functional power he just wanted
to figure out that the the blueprint of
proud power he I mean he had his own
biases that he definitely put in there
yeah and he went to fires like this wild
man but what they've done from late 80s
into the 90s is mind boggling what
they've done with his ideas and the
ideas of the other the post modernist
that were kind of kicking around at the
time right and we're now sealing it you
know even yet we're living in the sins
of Michele Foucault well so for some of
us I
I will ask just out of courtesy but I
know for certain that you will be in the
same camp yeah you not have the
experience of looking at some of the
stuff that we are now apparently
fighting about yeah and thinking if
you'd asked me five years ago whether
anybody was going to challenge the truth
it yet say the fact that there's a
difference between males and females and
it's not perfectly arbitrary I I knew
that there was like hints in that
direction I dia that we would be
fighting about whether or not a trans
woman
yeah and compete against people who are
born female in athletic competition
right I would have said and you think I
seen it right like it's it's it's so
it's disorientating and most people most
people feel like that like I think the
majority of people like what the hell is
going on with it some strange strange
like sleep universe or something like
that
well so it has been operating like this
very much from the 90s onwards we've got
they've got thirty years of scholarship
then tumblr comes along and makes it
super accessible and it's it's spread
like we're already kind of living in
there what is it they're they're kind of
moral hegemony if like my whole life has
been in this in this milieu the kind of
victimhood mentality but it very much
collided with the Internet
and all of a sudden it's it's absolutely
everywhere and it's in its I would say
purest form it's it's in in the form
that they light down in this inside
their scholarship well you know it'd be
interesting I'm not convinced that we
have a full understanding of why the
internet had the effect on it that it
did but it it allows very fringe ideas
that are held by isolated pockets to
congeal into a hole that they would
otherwise would not and it also it
allows a kind of tactical growth where
each one of these forays into the absurd
learns a bit about what it cannot do
what arguments are feeble and which ones
are forceful and so it learns and is
spreading in a way that is quite
dangerous yeah you know I mean it's it's
Darwinian but the it's it's selecting
for emotion and so the these that these
are so this this scholarship it's it's
navigating around these deep moral
emotions I mean a young would call them
like an archetypal type thing Jonathan
height would call them what are they
moral foundations they're kind of
revolving around it's very much care
harm in in the Jonathan hight way of
looking at it so they were revolving
around you I said they weren't policing
for sight anything scientific it was
more moral intuition yeah they're
they're circling around these moral
intuitions and they've created like it's
reams and reams and reams of work I rap
just circling around these moral
intuitions and policing this new
worldview and so you plug the internet
into that and it's something where we're
already living in this world where you
know social justice is it's it's kind of
our religion really like we it's it's
the most gripping moral system that we
have you know this Christianity yeah and
it's kind of on the outskirts of the
media and haman system and so it just it
field that those plugs right I feel is a
moral system that kind of moved across
the internet because the internet
selects for emotion and then you've got
things like the shooting videos and my
first film was it was a it was about a
video I talk about a racist incident on
a bus in Australia and they're all
exploding becoming very viral because
it's it's proof its world view of this
thing but if you actually look at the
stories behind these viral videos it's a
lot more complicated than that it's not
it's not this kind of cartoon world that
they've created it's based on this these
deep moral intuitions so there are a
couple of things I want to explore from
what you said yeah one of them has to do
with the fact that we as human beings
are not prepared for the modern
environment in a lot of ways but one of
them that's very clear is that our
ability to see events that are remote
and the bias in favour of seeing remote
events that are interesting rather than
ones that are not interesting results in
a total distortion of our sampling of
the world and so I remember as a kid
plane crashes were a regular topic of
conversation why because every time a
plane crashes and ends up on the news
its grisly there are bodies being picked
part by part it's hard to look away yeah
and that because it spends a lot of time
on your TV yeah you get the sense that
it's a common thing whereas
statistically speaking you're never
safer than when you're on a plane you
know even in the worst year you never
say for them when you're on a plane most
dangerous thing to you on a plane is if
you have a heart attack there or a
stroke and you can't get to the ground
fast enough but frankly anytime that
you're in that plane you're being
protected from all the things that could
happen to you on the ground yeah right
and so we get a very warped view based
on what's on the screen the same is the
milk on kids that went missing so sudden
there's all this Asteria around child
abduction totally which changed the way
we raise children in a completely
incoherent way
huge sociological events based on the I
guess it's technology like we're kind of
lighting against this technology and the
amount of time that people spend
interacting with a screen like that's
their world yet most people so it's a
lot of people leaving their screen and
not really even interacting with with
reality that they live in they actually
understand the world through this strong
I bet that will be reflected
neurologically I know we're not even
questioning with one fan so it's it's
it's very much I think this is
fundamentally technological it's
fundamentally technological but my guess
is we will start to see reflected in the
neurobiology of people yet this device
that because so much of your reward
structure is tied in through events that
happen over the device that you actually
begin to see through it yeah and what
that does mean is that you know what you
and I would consider normal interaction
is you know at best a second kind of
normal interaction rather than the real
deal and even I feel this myself I spend
way too much time on you too and I'm
trying to spend less but I'm only just
getting used to doing this kind of thing
and then when you invited me I was like
oh maybe I can squeeze out and we can do
it by Scott because I just felt like I
would be more comfortable in that
situation and I guess this is happening
more and more like yeah it is it's where
I'm comfortable I kind of in my room and
then I can I can look at everything
through a screen and be a little bit
more disconnected from it well you know
on the one hand I have kind of a mixed
reaction to video calls one way in which
video calls are just not as productive
as they should be yeah there's another
way in which they are better there is
some fraction of like facial expressions
and things that are conveyed well enough
through a video call yeah it's not as
good as sitting with somebody but it's
better than just listening to them but
there is something missing and I don't
know what it is I don't know what
channel it travels on but frankly my
enthusiasm for having a conversation
with somebody like you goes way up if
we're gonna be sitting in the same room
because much of what makes it
[Music]
you know that the right analogy is
really a corrective lens right the
corrective lens is for somebody who has
an eye that is seeing in a distorted
fashion you take a distortion to correct
for the distortion that you've got on
board we all have a distortion that
comes from the increasing role that
screens are playing in our perception of
what's actually taking place and why
and there's another correction that
comes from you and I sitting in person
you know it's not natural we've got yeah
devices here we are Todd's they're
people asynchronously out there who are
not talking back but we imagine what
they might think about what we're saying
yeah very unnatural yeah on the other
hand the very fact that some part of
this is natural that you and I are
sitting in a physical room having the
conversation yeah corrects for part of
it and there's but even my feeling of it
there's a lot of inputs here that are
making me a little more anxious than if
they were through a screen I've noticed
that like so I spent a lot of time
studying this stuff and and just editing
over the past year and I was going
outside less and less and less and then
it's like early on scent early onset
agoraphobia or something like that like
I don't know what happened but when I
went outside everything was louder and
it was it was hard to talk to people
like I and I've never been my
extroverted I grow like who is
extroverted guy and now all the sudden
it's like I don't know what's happened
and I know it's this green it's
something something to do with too much
time in the screen too much time by
yourself too much time in your thoughts
that's interesting that make you feel
different and I'm an artist so I'm
sensitive to those sort of things and I
think that this is happening I'm seeing
it in other people I'm seeing it in a
lot of people they were trading from the
world and they're interacting with the
world virus screen and that that is some
kind of so am I wrong so I I'm not
having this experience I I'm actually I
tend to be kind of introverted and my
life in the last it's not even since
evergreen from before that has forced me
I'm sort of a secondary extrovert where
I've had to get used to it and I have
now but true it was unnatural to me at
first so I'm in motion on the other
yeah but I'm imagining based on what
you're saying that there's a feeling of
like nakedness yeah when you're in
person yeah that is like you know behind
the screen it's like properly clothed
you're not revealing anything which is
really I mean I don't want to overreact
to it it's a little bit tragic that
people human beings are feeling
jeopardized by the presence of other
human beings in their physical space
like oh no particularly Millennials
right I'm a millennial and even the
generation under it's it is strange
they were there's this thing as this
thing going around like you can memes
are really good the memes that go out
they kind of give you an insight into
how the generation is feeling and
there's this there's a several like the
kind of classic memes about the
intrusion of a phone call
yeah and the phone call is a massive
intrusion it's like no no text me don't
write on me and it's it's it really is
an insight into where all our brains are
Bank brains are out so something
physiological happening because of the
technology we're surrounding ourselves
with so I wonder now that you mention it
so I am NOT a millennial I'm a Gen X
yeah that's not a boomer so no I like
that
so when I grew up in you know when I
earliest memories a phone was an object
that was plugged into the wall and a
cordless phone was kind of a thing yeah
you know it was I remember that being
like most phones were actually just
physically plugged in and then I
remember cell phones I didn't get one
for the longest time I didn't occur to
me that I needed one and then suddenly
they became ubiquitous and it was like
yeah you're just handicapped not to have
it but I wonder if the key reason that
people who are young you know millennial
and younger might be having some of the
experience you're describing is that
asynchronous communication allows
a lot of room for posturing yeah
figuring out how something is going to
land and delivering it in a way that you
feel like yep that one's ready for the
world we've become an actor right actors
are cool because their lines are written
for them that if you if you have the
time to script your your communication
and all of a sudden you're cool and you
would be you know right so this actually
dovetails with something I've heard
Jordan Peterson say it I've heard me say
it I've heard Ben Shapiro said that at
the point that you find yourself in
situations like this where something is
going to go into the world and it will
have some impact and you just have to
live with the aftermath of it you you go
into this mode where you are speaking
and then some part of you is watching
what you're about to say and checking
everything and I wonder if that's not a
bit lacking if your experience was that
a lot of communication is asynchronous
yeah if that's how you grew up then I
wonder if that's harder you know I can
do it in real time it's taxing yeah but
it's possible yeah but if my experience
was that your average communication even
interpersonal communication was
asynchronous then maybe that circuit
just isn't very strong yeah and it's
also you you I mean part of the being so
judgmental about everything everyone
says it's because they've had time to
think about it like people used to shoot
off the hip and say whatever they want
and it was okay who's okay to make
mistakes you know I wonder if this is
not actually playing a huge role here I
mean maybe this is exactly what you're
saying but i watch people get canceled
for something that I agree they
shouldn't have said Yeah right but it's
like wait that was fatal yeah you know
and it's like whoa that you're talking
about taking somebody's well-being and
zeroing it out over something that they
said sometimes it's not even what they
meant they just trying something out and
you know when I was teaching we had
these things called covenants students
and professors would
agree at the beginning of a course what
the rules were right and those could be
rules about grading how you you know if
something isn't to your liking what you
do about it and all that but I used to
include in that that everybody has the
right to take back what they've said and
restate it you can say that wasn't what
I meant
or it was what I meant but I no longer
think that everybody has that right and
you should speak knowing that you have
that right and you should treat
everybody else and then say have it
being human right it's normal yeah and
so maybe maybe your point is just all
right let's put it this way I've never
heard this anywhere else but I do it
does immediately strike me as an
important component here is that people
are being held responsible at a new
level because asynchronous communication
allows people to pretty stuff up more
than as normal yeah and so people aren't
used to the noise of people saying
something a bit tone-deaf and then you
know the the policing is a different
thing as well like there's another input
here which is so in the in our legal
just assessment system you you often
punish people as a to show everyone else
that that shouldn't be done yep I send a
message I guess deterrence yeah and so
within this this scripture
let's call let's call it there the Canon
it's racism is perpetuated through
discourses so the way we think about
things so someone puts their foot wrong
it's not actually the human that's doing
it it's it's a strange thing where we're
individual responsibility they don't
really consider it very much yeah it's
not the human it's the discourses
working through the human so if you
converge on it and get rid of it you're
actually you're you're actually going
after the evil that's in the world
you're not going after the human you're
going after the eagle because the
discourses are working through them it's
so when you start actually learning
what's going on here yeah see it cuz
it's so intuitive yeah and you can see
how something like that would spread as
a new met is a metaphysical system
that's spreading over everything and I
mean the technology is creating the
atmosphere in which this can take place
really quickly
and as we were talking about we could
talk all day about what the different
inputs that are making this a huge
cultural phenomenon but underneath that
the scripture description they've laid
all this out it's all there and they
they talk about it
unapologetically when you when you go
behind the closed doors of the Academy
yes okay I've got two places I want to
go I wanna make sure we don't lose them
I think they're both important so if I
forget remind me that I want to talk
about Yale okay okay what happened there
but first let's talk about the question
about these moral intuitions and I like
how you phrase it resonates for me so
there's this moral intuition and some of
these moral intuitions I think they're
not right as they're stated but you
could fix them right there the intuition
is correct it's just the phrasing is way
to hell off yeah but we're not even
phrasing like action so the old moral
intuitions are intuitions but they
unless you're lining them up with some
kind of empirical you know method to get
what you want based on those intuitions
and that's what are they're just
discharging feelings well let me let's
take an example so this is more concrete
okay let's take the idea that the
difference in performance that is to say
economic performance of people from
different racial groups is the result of
bias and unfairness mm-hmm I actually
suspect that that's probably almost
correct I think there's a lot all of it
down to that but you couldn't put that
at its blanket rule but you can't if you
can't assume it yeah but my guess would
be based on everything I've seen yeah
and everything I've seen includes an
awful lot of time tromping around in
other people's minds when they were my
student yeah you know I looked into
their minds in order to help them learn
yeah I in the process learned an awful
lot about them yeah yeah I'm I'm totally
open to that I actually think it's
probably the case yeah so I think if you
did just thought experiment level yeah
if you fixed the unfairness so that all
of the little threads that have carried
through one Jenner
to the next were actually just
neutralized and you started us all you
know in the same position with the same
advantage is the same access to
education and all I believe that almost
all of this would disappear and then
what you would find is that in general
people are very similar in their
capacity they're very similar in their
built-in desires and that basically
these massive differences that we find
in preference for activities and things
is all you know some of its arbitrary
yeah but it's based on the fact that
we've traveled different paths and had
different opportunities and so anyway
the problem is you cannot project that
onto the system as I say it's you can't
take it as an assumption yeah right
there could be differences yeah and they
might matter my intuition is that they
don't matter very much
big ones might exist between males and
females there's a very good biological
reason to expect differences there to
make them will fit for other things you
know what I mean like it's not right as
know it seems like a power imbalance
because of the culture but it's like
women are gonna be on average better at
certain things and men are gonna be on
average better at other things and
that's can't be the case that is that is
the nature between males and females and
that's awesome we like why not encourage
that and and and right I to that rather
than play against it well frankly I'm
I'm very up for a world in which we
absolutely free people to jumped out
yeah yeah and decide you know what I may
be female but I like the stuff that men
are more typically into and I'm going to
do that you know Heather is this way
yeah Heather's very mask oh yeah yeah
the world and I think that's great yeah
and I you know but when you're looking
at it on like I mean one to one you
should be looking at it in their kind of
way but I mean if you're looking at it
from a sociological two hundred thousand
feet off and you have to think in in
numbers right you have to think in bell
curves yeah because if you don't think
in bell curves and you're gonna hurt
people unnecessarily
you gotta you're to play to the bell
curves well that's that's the the whole
irony I'm getting at it
at the difference between the moral
intuition yeah and the thing that might
be rescued if you studied it carefully
the thing that you might find that
actually is the reason for the intuition
the extent of the intuition is there for
organic reasons yeah it's about
something if I'm right that if you did
neutralize advantages that people are
basically the same and responding to
different opportunities based on you
know their particular place in the world
then you could say something that
there's an X Factor mmm right the things
that make different populations function
differently has to do with a lot of
arbitrary things that are not inherent
the creature I want to click clear
something up here a little bit so my
when I say moral intuition I'm going
deeper than so at some point there is so
there's the what I find is very
difficult to explain
there is the intuition that that's an
emotional feeling right it's it's it's I
was often thought if they had some
symbolism it would be like Mary Mary
Mother of Christ with the baby and then
there's another symbol of the bear
protecting its its young all right this
is [ __ ] mode it's a mode that you can
click into and you get really feel it
and it's in the guts and that's the
evolution part of it so culturally so
that's the hardware that's that it's a
hardware we're working with as humans
it's Universal and it travels through
time and that's that I love looking if
I'm trying to find trying to triangulate
what these deep emotional feelings are
by looking at stories through our time
and you know the religious stories and
things like that
culturally we put a software on top of
that and that is a home for those moral
intuitions but underneath those moral
intuitions they're just they're kind of
driving is in an in a certain direction
getting us to make certain certain
decisions it's ism it's a movement thing
it's like the energy that's moving a
culture when you've got a moral system
on top of a culture but even just one
human he makes his decisions based on
his kind of
moral moral intuitions that the the
hardware that we're stuck with so when
you said that the moral tuition is
moving is something I do I do think
you're right it's the it's the software
you're more talking about the software
on top of it so they're they're canon is
it's it's creating it's it's creating a
different software that is a that is
primarily focused on this care harm one
this kind of bear protecting its cub
type thinking and you can see it you see
it in patterns and so I totally I
totally agree like it's gone at these
intuitions their intuitions and they're
gonna pull us in the right and wrong
direction and and a lot of people are
buying into buying into the stories
based on the intuitions and they're
being sold into it on quite logical
things at the same right but it actually
gets darker and crazier and weirder and
where the further you go into what
they're actually trying to sell to the
world does that make sense I'm very I'm
not articulate about these things
sometimes no I think he was articulate
but I have to tell you this is a place
where I think our what we biologists
teach yeah as to where the border is
between biology and other things is so
broken that we can't help but trip over
this at this place so let me just tell
you what I think I'm gonna give you a
preview of what I think we will
understand about humans 100 years for
still around the software layer the
software layer is composed of a couple
of things it's composed of what I would
call culture that is things that are
passed down and it is composed of things
that are learned in real time right they
may not be durable hmm
your software layer is composed of these
two things but they are just as much
biological as that which your genes
set in motion directly and so there is
something going on where these moral
intuitions are being searched for a
couple of things one they're being
searched for content and they're also
being explored in terms of their utility
and utility is relative to something
else that I think we teach very very
badly which is human beings are in some
ways just like every other creature but
in some special ways we do this
uniquely we are built for a lineage
against lineage competition the moral
intuitions are partially an exploration
of what might be true and they are
partially a claim that doesn't matter if
it's true if the question is is this
useful as this advance my lineage is
interest to say it out loud
and so this is very confusing because
it's a factual claim right the fact that
there are not equal numbers of men and
women in the ranks of programmers at
Google
and that that necessarily implies that
there is some sort of discrimination
taking place that's a claim it's a false
claim is there discrimination I don't
know but the idea that it has to be
there because there's a difference in
the numbers that's a false claim we know
that but it doesn't mean it's not an
effective claim and so anyway we're
seeing mixture of this sort of empirical
claim and the strategic claim that are
indistinguishable from each other yeah
and it's makes it very confusing to
confront it because you don't know how
to take it apart yeah but one thing if
we can just finish out the thread about
the moral intuitions and whether or not
they actually line up with something
that would be real if we studied it
the thing that I find so frightening is
that the way in which biases of the past
or arbitrary differences in starting
point have altered the fate of modern
people are so complex that you cannot
just come at them painting with a broad
brush right lots of this stuff may be
unfair and have nothing to do with
discrimination right Guns Germs and
Steel a great example the whole book is
about kinds of unfairness that have
nothing to do with discrimination yeah
they may result in discrimination but
they don't start there they're basically
you know did you have goats in your
environment or didn't you yeah and so
anyway it's a very difficult topic and
the moral intuition might lead you to
study it but what they're doing is
sabotaging the means by which you would
study it and figure out you know is
there a basis to the claim yet
we can read the degree of unfairness in
the difference in outcomes and that's
why I'm calling a theology yes because
it's a faith because they're feeling
they're feeling it out that's why
they've moved so far away into this into
this strange kids are calling a clown
world now because usually these moral
intuitions are grounded by inside the
Academy should be grounded by some
empirical evidence or general Riga you
know yeah or at least advancing the they
could be advancing the Western Canon but
they've decided to create their own kind
and shake the etch-a-sketch on
everything we've learnt beforehand if
you've actually raised by those yeah
they hit reset and then they've gone
started from the late 80s and started
again and but it's not scientific now
they've diverged into this strange area
of theology and it's so it's a it's a
startup religion it's the 30 year old
religion yes it's a 30 year old religion
and you know no 30 year old religion is
its is wise we we've tried a few times
before a lot of people die yeah yeah
alright so now let's pick up the the
Yale threat because I think things
convert so there's there's a thing that
I've heard routinely and you know we've
seen it a lot of different places but
you know Yale what the Christakis this
was particularly clear right you watched
these people chastising Nicholas
Christakis and the courtyard there and
you know this is easy for you and me to
interpret because we never you know that
was an early version but we've now seen
enough of these instances that it's just
you know it's that same tragic thing
unfolding but what you hear as a
critique is these people who are
chastising Nicholas are among the most
privileged people anywhere right how is
it that they are not recognizing that
they're at Yale but I actually think
this critique is wrong and here's why
because we are built for lineage against
lineage competition if you are a member
of a lineage that has faced
cooller obstacle an unfair obstacle and
then you as a member of that lineage
have found yourself in a privileged
position yeah it is actually
I think quite natural for you to speak
on behalf of the lineage that is still
lagging yeah and so I think it's very
confusing when you see it on a screen
because what you see is an individual
who clearly has a ton of privilege
acting as an oppressed individually and
identity four or four it's like they are
taking on the identity that they think
they should have it's a cartoon version
of their identity well but I'm not
speaking on behalf of their people were
speaking on their their behalf I think
personal bar I hate to impose this on
them yeah I think they're a little bit
confused about what is first of all I
think there's some bad actors and I just
want to dismiss them yeah what they're
doing is streaming that word and
uninteresting yeah we certainly know
that but for many of these people
they're not bad actors they are giving
voice to something that feels very real
I have a feeling that what they are
saying is has some truth in it but
because it's phrased in the individual
it is a paradox why is somebody who is
experiencing the kind of privilege that
somebody obviously is I don't care if
you're at Yale on scholarship you're
still there right you've got a launch
pad into the world that most people just
simply don't have but if you are
internally in some way that you cannot
understand or explain a representative
of a lineage that is actually lagging
for reasons that do have a lot to do
with history and unfairness then giving
voice to that at the moment that you
arrive in a place of privilege is not
false but it would need to be explained
so that you don't find yourself
chastising Nicholas Christakis who is
not involved in oppression as if he were
yeah and speaking from a position of
being oppressed which you aren't so why
why is it so confused you think because
the thing is is that there are
intuitions that are legitimate there and
we can both agree we agree that they're
acting on some intuition where there is
a level of legitimacy to it but it looks
absurd right because
identity for going on so I still blame
the cannon and I know that I'm gonna
draw all roads lead lead there because
okay so a huge text within their cannon
was Paolo Ferrari pedagogy of the
oppressed you have you read this I've
been counting I don't think I've read it
alright so maybe maybe Paolo I would
probably disagree with some of his stuff
but underneath it he's so he's frankfurt
school style marxist and he was living
in I think the 60s in Brazil and his
whole thing was alright we got to teach
these he was teaching people that
couldn't read the real the genuine down
trotted class I was teaching to read he
was figuring out all let's let's teach
them that they're oppressed but these
people don't know that they're oppressed
very Franklin school right let's teach
him let's teach them that they're
oppressed so they can liberate
themselves maybe maybe in Brazil in in
the 60s maybe I'm a little I'm still
[ __ ] off let these people make best of
this their own situations but
fast-forward to the applied post
modernists and you've got you've got
bell hooks who is named ellos Goa
guru and all these so she's written
teaching to do correct transgresses okay
name second one teacher to grant to
transgress so I mean you read it you're
like how I kind of get it it's like a
bit of a have you seen that in film
Dangerous Minds it's like all Dangerous
Minds fantasy like creating a little
lovely colty kind of thing with your
class really getting in with them it's
one I wanted to create a cult really and
so she's sprinkled all this postmodern
[ __ ] on it and then it's all of a
sudden she's bringing the same energy
that Apollo did to Brazil in the 60s to
Ivy League and so all of a sudden the
people these people have been taught
that they're oppressed and that being
taught in such a--such as like these
people are pretending that they are
their heroes who lived in different
times
different geographies right and they've
been taught in wooden the same
passionate with the same kind of zeal
the truth is simple yeah and if you
follow this path it results in this
amazingly better result
yeah it's just it's unfair and but think
about how much how many things you
actually have to tweak you need
post-modernism to be able to feel like
that right in our current situation so
think about how many things these
students need they need to tweak in
these students to get buy-in and then
all of a sudden you get them discharging
this emotion that feels like from us
there is something true there there is
something true but it looks absurd
because they've they've they've been
they're bought into this this this it's
it's very selfish as well I think cuz
these people living out their their
favorite civil rights heroes and a time
where it's not you don't do it it's not
warranted to that degree right oh I
think it is selfish in more than one way
that in effect basically people who
don't know how to question these
positive sounding sympathy isms
find themselves as pawns of a movement
that not only does it not really care
about their well-being in the end yeah
it has no plan for how to take care of
them and so you know you get a bunch of
college students to revolt against their
institution and to reject science and
then what are they going to do I call it
king of the rubble thinking they're
gonna be kings of the rubble Kings it's
harder it's hard to be too advanced
within this system let's turn it into
rubble and we'll be the Kings
do they know they're very sensitive I'm
gonna be okay if it turns to ball right
in the streets no I think this is you
know exactly what's gonna happen and
actually I think there's a trajectory
that inside of the university system
yeah you either have the ability to do
science or you do not yeah if you do not
have the ability to do science inside of
the university system it will move out
of the university system and it will
become something else yeah at which
point you will have universities that
don't have that thing I don't think
they're viable I think they will
collapse and so the point is to turn
your university upside down and reject
the science is to cause the thing that
maybe does off
you the possibility of pulling yourself
up by your bootstraps or the equivalent
and wrecking it and yeah king of the
rebel is about it's also yeah it's a
goal of university I mean Jonathan Hite
talks about this he figured this stuff
out quite well on on it from a slightly
different angle to I'm looking in at at
it but the tailless thing have you heard
his Taylor's thing so he either the
Taylor's of the university it used to be
about truth oh and now it's about so now
it's about change and that's what it is
it's like it's the the function of the
university has been hijacked it has been
adequately we need something we need
something we need that scientific rigor
and it doesn't necessarily have to be
prescriptive because the culture has to
look after the prescription of that and
and politics and whatnot not though not
the Academy when the Academy pulls in
change like how to use the science yeah
it's a church that's why I put a
prescriptive sociology based on moral
intuition that's what this side of the
Academy is doing and through the
administrative class is taking over the
entire trying to you know it's a it's
hitting up against a lot of a lot of
trouble but that's the goal there in the
church business so they're trying to I
mean the academies were with scholastic
monasteries before they became they
devoted themselves to science but they
could head back there they could head
back there and what they are doing wrong
at the moment is that they are allowing
that basically administrators are
pandering to the Church of moral
intuitions yeah and they are not leaving
a firewall between those folks and the
sciences and I mean this is why you're
sitting here talking to me yeah is that
they came after me it's not an accident
that they've not an accident is it right
no I see this is the weird thing is it
do you think it's because you have
confidence in your science that you kind
of stood just you stood against them and
then they came after you because it's
that it's the hardest thing isn't so
much of this so much of this movement it
seems so it seems so natural yeah but
someone has to know is like is is
is this some kind of the ideology
working through humans and then there
will naturally go to that that place or
is it explicit I think on you in your
case it would be that I mean your
personality right like you well if
someone's got if you know something and
someone comes after you gonna go against
them and that's oil and water I guess
yeah although I mean I think your
question has a precise answer I don't
know it precisely yeah I do have a sense
of what it is there is a very rare
characteristic in humans the
characteristic involves not being
persuaded by the degree to which other
people believe something in general a
human being who is faced with a room
full of people who disagrees with them
will change their opinion and the reason
this is not entirely nuts the reason is
because if you think about an ancestor
an ancestor who was alone in their
opinion on something that mattered was
in danger mm-hmm right they were in
danger of being outcast because even if
they were right being alone in that
belief is rowing in the wrong direction
and so we are wired to be very
frightened by the prospect of being out
of phase with other people on the other
hand I believe that a certain number of
people have to be capable of that thing
it probably comes at a substantial cost
it does is why I'm sitting here in this
room and not working on high scale
productions back home and in Australia
it right that theme right it's a high
cost it's a high car oh I often think of
it as a disability like not being able
to naturally go into the room and then
just become one of the other people like
it's it's you find yourself on the
outskirts of a lot of projects a lot of
you know institutions and things like
that like sometimes I look at the people
who can just be yeah magic oh sure yeah
I've got this weird disability that
makes me it's funny I have no desire to
be on the other side I died I was going
to hypothesize
that you have exactly the same thing I
think the place where we differs there's
some part of you that feels like that
would be easier and my feeling is I
can't imagine what you got a few more
years under your belt and maybe you've
got your brother and stuff so I find my
little tribes I got much room yeah well
I mean this is true having Eric and
Heather yeah a reality check you know at
worst a phone call away
changed every day I would be this way
anyway but the degree to which I might
imagine I was crazy yeah would be much
greater that's the hot pot as well when
everyone around you it makes you feel
creative nice and they call you crazy
they did I hate you like as well and
it's like because he was showing some of
them something that I want to say I
don't know well is I wanna you know
maybe I'm just chronically crippled in
this direction but I do want to steal
man the thing that they are applying
yeah I think it's a real thing and it
actually makes sense it just doesn't
make sense here at all okay so the point
I used to make to my students I used to
talk about him there was this great film
called the hunters about the cones on
the Bushman and basically an
anthropologist followed a kung son
hunting party on a hunt and they hunted
you a giraffe and kill it and he
documents it and anyway so I would talk
to my students about what about somebody
who was on such a hunting party who
looked at the leaves of a tree you know
imagine some tree like a birch in which
the bottom side and the top side of the
leaf four very different colors and they
shake in the wind that person might look
at the leaf and think you know that
implies something about a binary you
might be able to encode all kinds of
things in a binary indeed there might be
all sorts of things about us they are
encoded in some sort of binary form that
person might have had the first thought
that ultimately thousands of years later
leads to a computer yeah right the
answer to the guy who won't shut up
about the shimmering of the leaves is
shut up
we're hunting yeah starvation is what
happens if we don't do it well yeah I
don't know what you're on about with
respect to those leaves but stop being
on about it or you're out
yeah right so my point would be there
are times when pulling in the same
direction is vastly more important than
seeing some precise truth and then there
are other times where exactly the
opposite thing is that yeah yeah and my
feeling is we are in exactly the
opposite case right we need people who
see with clarity because the people who
know where they're going are confused
every single one of them right we're
people are looking there must be another
people looking for the people with
clarity as well and there's a lot of
people standing on soap boxes that don't
have that clarity they're potentially
the guys looking at the branch and going
what if that's some kind of absolutely
backward binary with an upside down yeah
yeah I think a lot of people have this
sense right I have the sense that we got
to look for these people well I want
them it's times times like viously
strange times wherever messiahs pop up
and cults bubble up out of nowhere yeah
both things happen is that you get some
people who actually have insight and do
see ya half through the bottleneck and
then you have other people who sound
similar but either are delusional or are
disingenuous well I think I'm did you
have a point you wanted to go on well
that'd mean I do have a significant one
yeah yeah no no go on I want you to keep
going so this this all leads to
somewhere else that I wanted to bring up
with you yeah which has to do with
something that your film revealed to me
about the event that I lived through the
one that I am now so identified with
that I just didn't know yeah and it
you'll see this all comes back to an
earlier part of this conversation in a
way that I think is useful I looked at
the video of the moments where those
students for people who haven't seen it
or don't remember these are students
I've never met who came charging through
the door chanting for me to be fired or
to resign they you know they're
surrounding me I'm trying to film them
which they want to block but they very
much want to film it so that they can
put into the world as you say they're
proud
it and I reacted away so many of the not
a single one of them knew me I don't
think I'd had a conversation with any of
them but some of them didn't even really
have any familiarity with who I was or
why I was being protested I learned much
later that they had been sent to protest
they had been given a piece of paper
yeah and at the point that I stopped
read that I reacted in a way that
confounded their story of the racist
monster that they had been meant to
protest they were like not sure what to
do yeah as the emotion right so they
there's a point in the video where very
tragically from my perspective they go
from actually interacting with me to
just chanting one yeah the paper and if
you listen to what they chant on that
paper they're talking about who they're
there to represent yeah they're actually
making an appeal to my students they
wanted my students to flee from me and
to join that amorphous moral intuition
church on the spot
imagine what that scene would have
looked like if my students had done that
right now it didn't even occur to me
even four months afterwards until I saw
your film it did not occur to me that
what they were hoping and inspecting was
that I would be abandoned by my students
my students weren't going to do yet and
the reason my students weren't going to
do that was because of the dynamic that
existed in my classroom which none of
those students knew because they hadn't
been my student Yeah right Heather and I
well not only that can can I yeah I did
hear a story of one of your students
that said that you're at the time
teaching them about witch hunts oh yeah
it was on the board like so a before
what kind of I mean science is kind of a
little bit of an inoculation against
this kind of stuff if you can if you're
there with it right like well let's be
clear about why the witch hunt stuff was
on the board yeah okay there are two
reasons one of them you could say was
almost prophetic in this case yeah which
was that the subject matter of the
course the final course that I probably
will ever teach is a college professor
this
subject matter of the course was if you
imagine that civilization is headed off
a cliff there are two questions what
should we be doing instead of what we
are doing and how might you shift
civilization to start doing that thing I
don't know anybody who knows the answer
to the second thing there's no good
answer to how you would get power and
apply it properly to make things work
so let's abandon that question let's
focus on the second question if we had a
mechanism to set something in motion
that wouldn't have the defects of our
system and wouldn't run us off a similar
cliff
what were those rules rules be right
because free ourselves from the question
of how and focus entirely on the
question of what well that is the answer
to the question that the church you're
talking about does not ask right the
church that you're talking about is
stuck in how do we fix this object and
get our share from it yeah rather than
maybe the object is just around its
course and maybe it's time to think of a
new object in which casing in the place
yeah right no proactive solutions ever
it's the whole thing is comprised the
whole thing is broken yeah it's gonna
kill us all if we don't fix it and so
let's think about you know maybe this is
just easier to solve in terms of solving
each of the issues and you know I don't
mean you know I'm not talking about
utopian solutions I'm talking Pareto
optimal solutions where you're not a
hundred percent free but you're eighty
percent free and you know what so is
everybody else because it's a quite fair
system yeah etcetera but the the the
second reason that witch-hunts were on
the board in my class was that I was
having this experience where as the
college descended into madness I took it
on myself to go to every meeting which
nobody does there are just too many
meetings and so people go to some
percentage every year I started going to
everyone because bombshells were dropped
at everyone and nobody was in a position
to track everything that happened yeah
right and so it sort of felt like it was
a necessary thing and so I started to do
it and
what that meant was that part of my mind
was beginning to see the entire picture
of what was happening to this
institution and I was becoming a target
because I was the person who anytime
they left an opportunity to raise your
hand and say hey this is not such a good
idea yeah you know my hand went up and
so anyway as I was being accused of more
and more preposterous stuff by
colleagues you know who shouldn't be
accusing me of anything I'm just simple
I'm doing my job I'm raising my hand and
asking questions about what we're doing
you know as that was unfolding it began
to become clear that I was going to
become the scapegoat and so anyway
imagine that that's all true and imagine
a college in which the good professors
have very close relationships with their
class yeah where I am NOT just some
abstraction to them but I come in and to
the extent that I'm preoccupied by the
fact that my colleagues are going and
saying around me
yeah there's no honest way not to have
some sort of interaction with them and
say look here's what's throwing me I'm
watching crazy stuff unfold in the
college and I don't know what to do
about and so you know they had some
sense of something that they couldn't
see over in faculty space yeah going
bonkers
yeah and then it emerges through the
door however here's the tough part
there was a nasty accusation that was
periodically levelled at Heather and me
while we were teaching it was that the
community of very committed students who
circulated between our classes and who
became very energized about evolutionary
biology that that was a cult know in
writing yeah and it wasn't and you know
sometimes students would bring this up
like they're people who chat would
challenge them yell you're part of the
call of Breton Heather can i interject
there for a second because I think
evergreen was is I mean it had a
beautiful structure but it also had the
most dangerous structure you can have
finger because you
universities when you when you
introducing people to knowledge it's
like one step out from a cult really
like it's it's it's just depends on what
you want to do with that and then to be
put with students for that long a period
of time you guys going away with them
Naima was doing projects with them
outside of the class and there's this
bond yeah if it gets created so you
could see I'd be evergreen is probably a
series of call a cult right like well
knowledge knowledge cults some summer
some are good some of that I would I
would totally phrase this a different
way no I don't I don't think you're
wrong I just think the labels are what
it is is that cult is the pathological
version of something that I'm not
exactly sure what to name it yeah right
yeah so oh do you know what it is what
so I have been thinking about this so
you would have brought people in in not
not too dissimilar very dishonest
fashion but it's it's he's some
knowledge it does excellent things for
us you can learn it too and then go out
in the world and do what you want with
it
yeah whereas a name teaching to current
transgressor you know this kind of
milieu is we have the solutions we know
what we want you to think and we will
instruct you and then you go out in the
world and be just like us it's it's this
so you're absolutely right that a
university a functional one yeah is a
series of things that have some of the
components of a cult yeah the real deep
question is do the people at the head of
the room are they honorable and do they
know something
in which case using that that power
that's there can be liberating for
students or are they self-interested or
confused in a way that they will mislead
these PDS into self yes and so you know
I used to I'm always cautious about
saying this because seduction has a
sexual connotation yeah that isn't part
of what I'm talking about yeah but
seduction is a question of making
somebody wants something to motivate
them yeah right that can be used for ill
Rakeem used for good but I always
thought that pedagogy teach mmm was best
thought of as a kind of intellectual
seduction if you're trying to get people
to do stuff by threatening them with a
loss of credit or a bad grade if they
don't do it you're not gonna jump but if
you say look I'm not gonna make you do
this I'm not even necessarily gonna give
you a bad evaluation if you don't do it
well but you should want what I'm trying
to deliver because you'll be more
powerful if you have it yeah and you
know in on my first day of class
typically I gave a hell of a speech
every time and it was basically you
might not want to be in this class here
are the reasons you don't want to be
here here are the things I'm not good at
as a professor and then if none of that
scares you off here are the reasons you
might want to stick around yeah and I
would say you know I used to speak in
what I would call riddles and the idea
of speaking in riddles is that it causes
the conscious mind to become active
because you can't parse them
straightforwardly they weren't really
riddles yeah they were just little
paradoxes and I would say look I
actually want you to leave my class
knowing less than you did when you came
in but the stuff that you know I want it
to be much more powerful and I would say
you could graduate college with the
equivalent of a giant trailer full of
knowledge right or you could have a
little backpack full of stuff that's so
powerful that it actually outweighs
what's in that trailer and that's the
stuff that you should pursue so the
interesting thing here is that I'm
trying to get in the head of the people
that I'm studying and so if you're
operating from a completely different
worldview science is a cult to them like
the the the the norms the bell curves
are a cult and they're they're trying to
I call them the second culture because
they're designing a second culture based
on being other from the main culture
yeah and if you this seduction you talk
about it is it's everywhere if you can
get if you get a camera in any one of
these rooms there's it's this big
emotional
hmm it's the seduction but the content
is the contents know where it is
somewhere it's a it's a it's a cohesive
worldview now it's based on offense
based rules but it has a different
metaphysics it's it's like if you have
to in order to buy in you have to shake
the edges get some Western civilization
so there's this queering thing there's
all these strange things they do that
replicate what you would go through
you're reborn into it right like you
leave your family you leave the world of
norms and then you're reborn into this
new I guess it's a group of outsiders
and they teach you that the world is
designed in a completely different way
than you had imagined and it's a
completely destructive thing but I can
imagine that they were building their
own little cult and then they're like
this I can see how they could see what
was going on in the other classes as a
cult
do they had to the kids its warring
factions really it's it's warring
factions you can see it using the
students
oh the students are the soldiers in this
battle there's a tacit conspiracy
between the the students is an
audiological conspiracy but the students
and faculty and that's one thing that I
want the student leaders and the faculty
have this tacit yeah it's how to explain
like the the way that institutional
mechanisms are weaponized against
certain teachers like yourself and Peter
Bergeron and things like that
yeah it's through a complaint the
complaints usually come from a student
or someone who is sure but then all of a
sudden the the institutional mechanism
kicks into place and it uses that
complaint to then asked ask the
problematic person but it's problematic
for usually from an ideological
perspective not not like these are minor
complaints these are very very minor
complaints that a lot of people are
getting kicked out of their universe
however totally and you know the irony
of ironies was that one of the things
that Heather and I were delivering was
you know a Guns Germs and Steel Plus
mechanism for understanding how we did
end up where
it's sort of like the scientific version
that to the extent that there are tools
to be had to liberate us from the legacy
of oppression they are scientific yeah
and so yes the the phony version had to
come after the real version yeah the
real version was very inconvenient just
as any place where a person of color and
evergreen said they didn't feel
oppressed resulted in a allergic
reaction these are the last ones the
right exactly
so you you were you weren't a pathway so
they so the the students that came to
you we're told that you you were having
a cult you say you were halfway through
that story oh well so I think the
question is what is the what is the the
version where the dynamics I mean it
wasn't a cultist thing that Heather and
I were doing wasn't remotely a culture
but we would say to our own students
when they would report to us that
somebody had accused them of this they'd
say you know bunch of people said I was
in the cult of Breton Heather it was a
very simple response which was you know
that in class you are expected to
question us at the front yeah yeah
that's the difference right absolutely
expect and that if you don't do it I
mean personally I used to engage in this
thing which I have a feeling would look
a little off if you didn't see enough of
it to get what it was about but if I got
the sense that a student was telling me
what they thought I wanted to hear
rather than what they would believe yeah
I would use that and I would lead them
out onto a branch yeah you know by
signaling what I wanted them to say and
then I would cut the branch off behind
look what we're talking about here the
responsibility that you have as a
teacher yeah it's actually very delicate
and could potentially to be taken like
think about how that responsibility can
be taken Oh like that look and then look
at the EDS ed schools this is this is
exactly it is it's frankly it's a
[ __ ] sacred responsibility it really
is a sacred responsibility and anybody
who either doesn't know what they're
talking about yeah or isn't
well-intentioned enough to wield that
thing carefully is a huge hazard to the
people yeah in
their classes and and not only that you
can scale that human up there is a lot
of them and they're all they're attached
to these disciplines so I mean I look at
this stuff and it's it's it's horrifying
to me because you're describing quite a
beautiful process right giving someone
the tools from from which they can leave
the school and then create something of
their life well but it's giving someone
the weapons they can use to ruin their
life for themselves is what's happening
on the other end that's it it's like the
educational equivalent of cutting yeah
you know right like they're being given
sharp tools and taught how to injure
themselves the other thing is it's not
just beautiful when the students leave
right armed with these really powerful
analytical tools it's beautiful once the
students understand what it is that
they're doing yeah right so this was the
thing the reason that that Heather and
my students got accused of being in a
cult was that they came back from class
very energized by what we were talking
about they didn't necessarily agree yeah
they wanted to talk about it outside of
class it had a life I felt that I felt
that around to you with hung and a
couple times and I felt that around you
and Heather you see some magic I haven't
said that to Heather you guys see some
magic I want to see what you see it just
comes when someone loves something it
comes out of them all right well and
it's such a joy you know here's the
thing once I got good I didn't mean I
was there for 14 years yeah at first I
was I was like being thrown into the
deep end
yeah and literally what happened to me
was they needed a teacher mm-hmm and
they called up Heather and they're like
can your husband teach does he know
anything yeah I definitely yeah and then
she looked at me and we're like well
we'll find out you know but they right
so they they literally said right a
course description for us to put in the
course catalog and wrote the craziest
thing I can come up with I wrote it I
wrote what I wanted
yeah and it was it was that it was a
course called adaptation and evolution
of organisms mechanisms and ideas yeah
and the idea was that these three things
evolve in a parallel but not identical
way yeah let's explore that and I wrote
you know an abstract to this thing it
was just like I know they're gonna
activist but maybe they'll love ya
there's a starting point they were like
good do it yeah right and then I had a
bunch of students walk through the door
and they were ready to play yeah it's a
good class right something about that
description caused the right people yeah
really and then it was just like so much
fun to walk in and see how far we could
move in in a you know a three hour
period or whatever but anyway after 14
years of this this became quite
efficient yeah right it was a question
of there was a landscape we had to
explore it there's actually not an order
that we have to explore it in it's not a
linear presentation the way you might do
chemistry chemistry or something it was
like it was more like walking into a
forest with students and saying let's go
look at this over here you know here's
what these guys are doing so anyway that
thing once you get a community of people
who a there's always somebody in the
room who's ready to play you know back
and forth with the professor you say
something paradoxical they say but what
about this and you say ah but what about
that and then once you know once the
others in the room begin to get the idea
a that they are safe yeah that they can
explore that it doesn't fall apart that
if they're wrong publicly it's not a
disaster that they end up looking smart
in the end because they do come up with
stuff that's novel sometimes they come
up with stuff the professor doesn't even
know right it's sort of addictive hmm
and anyway that thing unfolding inside
the classroom was very threatening to
the things unfolding in other classroom
it's so it's so complex what happened
there I it's the gravity of the
Evergreen story because it speaks about
so many different things yeah there's so
many different threads and this I I can
see your own benjamín voice you just
what is it two years down the track now
he's still talking about it and I'm
tangling it and and yeah it's something
there's something about what happened
there this is the layers the layers that
are in there well I'm so going right
because there's some so there's that
coming together series that I looked
into and thought this is like clearly an
insight into what the hell's going on
here
they've doubled down on that they're
doing another I don't know if you saw
the
recently but ya know I another coming
together tearing apart series circuits I
don't understand how their convictions
grow stronger as the evidence that they
are on the wrong track also grow
stronger you know that's that's the hard
part is at what point you get shaken out
of that moral community you know yeah it
it's stunning I mean I it's also
worrying like it's I think there's
something particularly strange about the
Washington area because I think that
Puget Sound there's a lot of a lot of
roads lead back there within the
scholarship and all these strange things
that I see so I think that there's
something particularly skewed within
this this Washington area that some that
Evergreen is do you have any insights
into into that that's in it this is pure
observation and I'm wondering if there
if these connect if these dots
connecting something in some strange way
well it'd be very interesting if they
were you raise the issue of the schools
of IDI which Lyle Asher who's here yes a
short lens we has been talking about so
we should explore that I don't know if
that's connected to what you're saying
what is it that you see in the Puget
Sound area I mean you know the tenants
that they were talking about at the
start of several meetings that are
because I'm monitoring this through
anything I can YouTube videos
scholarship yeah um some writings and
what is that race and pedagogy they have
conferences there D'Angelo's a big
player there and a lot it seems as
though there's another militant answer
for person that was teaching there
there's been three or four other things
where I've just seen the logo on
something like insane that I've read
like I've gone wow this is too insane
cuz usually they have to have to sell it
right like a the Celt like there's this
insane version of it yeah but they still
have to sell it within to make it work
within the academic university structure
and so it's it's hidden and usually you
can tell when you're reading something
hidden but then occasionally you'll see
this thing is like it's bit
yeah and a few of them have led back to
that that applies so then I think what
it is it so I was thrown a little bit by
your question because it's like well the
level of rainfall but I think the fact
is that but I think what you're
describing is that there's a critical
mass necessary to do the ideal honor
yeah and so the idea laundering doesn't
show up in full force unless you have
enough you know mirrors to bounce the
laser off yeah at which points hey guys
the coast is clear let's get weird right
exactly
so it may be that there happens to be a
concentration of particular things that
allow a ill-formed conception hmm to
make it into daylight here yet just
maybe for accidental reasons or
arbitrary ones well and I mean I get a
sense here in in Portland it's very it's
very left already so something was going
to bubble up like he did wouldn't it
wouldn't get a bunch of I mean do these
areas are they are they predominantly
left-wing are these kind of this is
definitely not swing states right
something about he there's this weird
experience I've had with I mean I'll
call them friends it was it was an odd
situation so I grew up in Australia and
I did a lot of work a lot of different
works factory jobs and things like that
and I remember moving to w.a and there
was these conversations with some people
that I was working with landscaping
there without talking about the
Aboriginal community and it was this
strange experience of them being quite
racist but like openly racist and I was
like I didn't I still wanted to be their
friends so to work with them yeah but I
did want to call them out and then it
was it was this odd experience of what
do I let that go
become the outcast right and I wasn't
going to work with this for long so hang
on whatever hole whatever I'll just
leave I'll leave that go just to keep
the peace and move on I'm not gonna
change the way of thinking and so that
experience I mean that's it's kind of
stuck with me and then coming over here
to Portland I had the same experience
but they were talking about white men it
was so weird so I was sitting there I
was sitting there and they're going on
speaking about white men like with hate
and it was like yeah these these white
guys I'm dating they're the terrible oh
god I hate them they all they do is play
video again just so useless and then oh
you're this wall like this cartoon
figure of what a white man is and there
was no really they could have been
talking about specific people without
talking generally and I'm sitting there
going I want to be friends of these guys
but this is a [ __ ] conversation like
this is it's the same thing it's the
same thing different in well I think
what you're getting at is super
important and the parallel is a really
interesting one in some sense human
beings have a mode yeah when we are
competing lineage against lineage we
have a mode there are certain ways we
sound when we are for example about to
make war on some other group right when
you're about to make war on some of the
group you dehumanize them write stories
in Hutus they said a cockroach a lot of
the time side of cool and cockroaches
Evergreen State College the police
officer that calling a cockroach totally
it's a question of making somebody out
to be subhuman yeah vermin pathogen
comes up a lot and we are watching this
unfold in Western civilization we're
certain it's clearer how it happens in
the university because some part of the
university culture is about saying
things publicly about bringing ideas
into the light and so we see it there
more clearly we were talking a little
bit about Lyle Asher who has unearthed
another thread that is much harder to
see and in fact when I first read his
work my thought was this is really
important and I would have missed it had
he not done this work I was only just
coven he just collided with his book so
you want to say what what he's told
I just want to kind of map out what I'm
what I'm doing now cuz so I've been
lucky enough to watch a book come
together that's coming out with within
the next few months why Helen placards
and James Lindsay so Helens 910 years
deep into looking at this this cannon I
guess specifically the kind of
scholarship there's social justice
scholarship and so her and Jim and a
little bit of contribution from me over
the course of the past two years has
they've mapped out the idea space and it
was clear to me we kept running into the
schools of Education and pedagogy
pedagogy is a big thing so the theory of
teaching and that kept popping up and so
they've they've created this map in
cynical theories it's mapped it out and
I think it could potentially be a big
event in mmm figuring out where this
problem is actually stemming from but
there's this big black hole because we
keep running into this thing that we
haven't looked into properly and then
all of a sudden this week I shot with
Lyle Asher as part of the film and we
got to talking and then I went to look
at his work and so he has mapped out
that the schools of Education and how
this kind of spread through these the
low standards within the School of
Education and they have moved from these
I guess there were weak bodies right
there were kind of a weak body that that
some kind of disease started operating
yeah their immune compromised yes
compromised that was quite weak right
now for a lot of reasons we've got taken
over ideologically and then they've
moved an administrator class that have
become educators so they've gone back
from administrative in back into the
education thing so it's it's it's
mapping so there's these this is cannon
and ideas and then how its actually
operating in the real world and I think
Lyle might be well I'm definitely gonna
keep in touch with him put it that way
oh yeah know his stuff is is
mind-blowing so the studying of the
schools of IDI it's you know most of us
don't even think about schools of at
half and has it come up in
you're thinking about how civilization
works but it has its a because it's a
weak node and because so much comes from
it it's a very dangerous vulnerability
but the thing I'm grappling with is
there's a distinction between what the
movement says that it thinks and what
how it works and the thing that concerns
me most is that the only way that this
movement delivers something positive to
those who have signed up for it in the
end is through some sort of very
frightening Maoist mmm takeover in which
it actually has the power to reallocate
resources on a massive scale I don't see
that as very likely it does
organizationally so within a certain
organization if you get enough it will
buy in you can advance using your
oppression variables quite beyond what
you deserve to advance or it's it's an
easy path I mean there's a lot of
competition around in all these places
now and it's like this extra element of
competition that you can kind of ride so
this is this is where I was heading
maybe I shouldn't say the only way it
delivers right you were heading the only
way it delivers in a fashion that
matches what it advertised yes is some
sort of a Maoist I take over yes yes
yeah what it actually amounts to is a
kind of affirmative action at every
scale which I have to tell you game
theoretically is a non-starter
I'm not saying affirmative action can't
work although I think what we've learned
through the affirmative action
experiment is that the Devils in the
details yeah but the idea that every
classroom is an opportunity to adjust
well-being by silencing certain people
and elevating the voices of others that
every courtroom might be a place I mean
just a simple fact that what is a crime
may be shifted so that
some people have more leeway to commit
crimes and other people have less leeway
to commit crimes now on the one hand
that's how it's been a racist court
system that's the justification for the
new caste system which is a reverse of
yeah and in some senses it has been you
know I mean II that's it's more it
hasn't it hasn't right when it's when
it's working well it doesn't well it was
hard for me isn't a stress these things
are off right right well I want to
actually about that from because I mean
as you must be aware Australia is
something of which Americans are well
aware and simultaneously not aware at
all but the fact just just take a an
ugly example up until very recently it
would have been almost impossible in an
American Court for a black woman to
successfully charge a white man with
sexual assault right so in effect white
men have had the ability to rape black
women in the US and not have the courts
step in is that I have no idea but it is
so inconceivable as an American is so
inconceivable that you know prior to
1950 that such a court kids that if a
white man had raped a black yeah yeah
that she would end up getting her day in
court and the court would hear this as a
legitimate accusation it's horrifying
yeah like that [ __ ] really hurt me and
that's why I think that's all I know and
there's a lot of energy there to play
with but yeah that's but you know I mean
I don't know I'll be curious when this
podcast emerges if anybody thinks I'm
wrong yeah about this but know that
courts have been slanted and they've
been slanted in a way that's fallen on
certain people's shoulders in a way that
it hasn't fallen on others what happens
if you say well it was like that for so
and so many years we're now flipping
and it's gonna be the opposite way right
a that is not going to be stable right
and that is not to say that what
happened was in any way acceptable it
wasn't but you're talking about
destroying civilization by naively
turning the tables on a historical fact
and anyway it's a it is a lethal
approach to solving this problem taking
a classroom and allowing certain people
to speak and other people not being able
to speak is also it's the same thing but
yeah but the weird thing is is it's a
difference between something happening
subconsciously or you know as a result
of these forces that are underneath us
and also the the system was aspiring not
to be there so if something was
happening it was happening implicitly
through that and then if they do that
xsplit explicitly so then they're not
just they're explicitly changing the
system to be racist explicit explicitly
as opposed to as opposed to just
something that the the probably the
problems would occur right but they're
not explicitly occurring they've
embraced racism as a solution yes and
they've defined it out of it as one
critical race theory right the whole the
whole game that's what it is and so for
some of us this is absolutely jarring
because as much as I agree that there is
more unfairness than the system
acknowledges more remaining unfairness
the idea of abandoning the pursuit of
fairness in favor of some compensatory
kind of racism is it's obscene it's
obscene and it it robs this of any
legitimate mm-hmm so anyway I don't know
where where we end up with it but just
the simple recognition that if you stop
listening to what it says yeah and you
look at what it actually pursue
that's what it's doing is its timing it
is it's saying that when you look at the
if you look carefully at the cannon you
look carefully you can see and that's
it's really really hard like I've had
even problems with talking to my sisters
about this stuff either from the outside
it looks like I'm getting drawn into the
role right or something like yeah dad
and it's like and remember you being
that gun like I'm not that guy you have
to see what I crazy it's so ugly
underneath this earth have to look past
it's it's like sanitation to bring
someone up to speed luckily I've family
right there so I've got that ability to
sit with them for a long time and tell
them why I'm not a monster but most
people are a few doors of clothes back
home in Australia as a result of me
looking into this stuff well that's
that's the other thing is that I think
when people they can't hear you or when
I try to convey why it is that we are
not where people expect us to be based
on the values that we hold we can't take
their answers too seriously because the
thing that the movement that we are
talking about does so effectively is
change the incentives of individuals so
that it is easier to go along than it is
to resist you just drive the costs up to
people who resist in any form so high
that it takes very unusual people to
choose to pay yeah and what happens then
is people will rationalize what they are
doing so if you're a coward right if
you're a coward
then you don't want to find yourself
having to explain to your family why
you're not actually in the all right
yeah right yeah so maybe it's easier to
just embrace the platitudes and to do it
enough virtru signaling that you are no
longer suspect yeah and then I'm
imagining I don't know how other
people's minds work but were I defined
myself in that position which I would
not allow myself to but if I were to
find myself in that position the pain of
having said what I didn't believe in
order to get myself out of trouble
would be so great then it would be
easier to rationalize it actually I do
believe that yeah and so I think this is
unfolding throughout the entire thing is
that people are convincing themselves of
positions that they would not ordinarily
be compelled by because it is the only
solution to the problem that they've
been given you do that long enough and
you actually believe that you know it's
not there's no kind of process there you
get so a lot of people don't know what
they believe as well so they're on
they're in this they're kind of using
their intuitions to go through a liberal
unlike the left and all that sort of
thing but if you actually bring it down
you actually explore what what what it
is you believe it's harder to shake or
something like that like there's some
people who are who aren't getting swept
up in this things cuz I'm I know what I
believe oh I I know exactly you have to
change a lot like it for some people for
to buy into something they have to
change a few little things yeah but it's
like I actually you if you want me to
join this enterprise which is a foot and
everyone's back home wanted me to join
it means I would have to change my
understanding of human nature I would
have to unchanged my understanding of
what being a liberal is I would have to
change and the damage I would do to
myself for changing those things would
be far worse than anything I can do to
them so yeah so no it's the well I I get
this completely and in fact the canoe
meeting is the perfect example because
you know as I'm so I walked into that
room and sat down in what socially felt
like the seat to sit down in and then
suddenly realized I was in front of
these cameras right it's great for me
yeah but what it meant was that I was
standing there as we were all back in to
enter the canoe and yeah sure off to the
magical land of equity everybody filed
past yeah and some of them will cachet
they do the fact there are ones every
time I see that a good there ones who I
know were embarrassed of what they had
that I found there was some people who
you like a look out of the corner of the
eye like oh they looked right at me they
were my friends and they knew that this
was wrong yeah and then yeah and then
they had to look me in the eye and see
it and I look to the right exactly I
mean I almost and I couldn't ride that
like if I wrote that I'd be really proud
of myself that that's shot that once all
right no it sounds like captured it it
actually happened but the other thing
what it sort of captures is that one
option for me in that room technically
mmm must abort their canoe yeah and the
simple basis that equity is desirable
and that yeah you know yada yada yada
there wasn't a chance in the world that
I was getting on their can that that
says something about you like that's a
beat it was a big move not to get on
that camera
you know what would have thought oh yeah
it was fated with Oh a bunch of I would
have lashes anyway I would have walked
on the tops of the seats to get out not
to board their goddamn canoe yeah and so
you know I mean it's all in that room
yeah got people who don't really know
what's going yeah you've got people like
the ones you described who walked by me
with shame in their eyes because they
knew that we both knew what was going on
yeah you got me who's like you know if
I've got a burrow out the wall yeah not
getting on your can you go Benjamin
Vaughn a camera magic the land of equity
but the real question at some level is
if we accept and I think you do that the
movement says a bunch of things that
don't add up it's internally consistent
but they don't add up if you evaluate
them from a grounded external
perspective but that it's highly
effective because it puts people in a
bind and gives them one option to solve
their problem and that one option
involves embracing these wrong ideas
what we who are not easily persuaded to
join them
our doing wrong is we are not
understanding that it is our obligation
to figure out how to honorably
counteract that strategy and I mean
maybe maybe you aren't maybe I'm
speaking for myself and yeah maybe you
are figuring it out maybe that's what
your fellows are looking at it we draw
into it and I'm spending a long time
with this I mean Douglas Murray said
this as well he he's written his book
that's taken the battle to the gates of
the university and I think that the
cynical theories will take it right into
the center now but he said himself like
after you start looking at this stuff
and you you can't stop it like you kind
of get drawn into it cuz you're like
holy crap it is come it is completely
different than the like iceberg tip
right away that we get we get shown and
it's I just think that it's I just go
there and then be productive create art
and I think that that's probably it's
the only solution I know well gets me in
a lot of trouble though so I don't know
how to operationalize what I think I
know about this what I think I know is
that there are always I don't know if
I'm even topped here in this probably
yeah but in terms of resisting this kind
of thinking yeah you know I mean maybe
start somewhere else my scientific work
my scientific approach absolutely
requires me not to be persuaded by the
fact that absolutely everybody disagrees
that's how you find new scientific stuff
that matters if you're persuaded by the
fact that everybody disagrees with you
you cannot traverse new ground in
science because everybody will disagree
with you at the beginning right so my
professional mode is born of that same
instinct which is well it's interesting
that everybody disagrees with me but
maybe that's even a sign that what I'm
onto is important well I think I've had
similar training in that well I think
that everyone to like I don't know how
to explain my ideas mhm and every time I
have everyone goes it's a stupid idea
like the industry doesn't want to look
after or whatever and then all of a
sudden I went well you know what screw
you guys I'm gonna learn how to use a
camera I'm gonna edit and I'd do it and
then all this awesome and then the
audience gets it and they go this is
amazing
and it's like so it's a similar thing
it's like I've kicked in the dick
constantly and with with the middleman
between what I want and so yeah it's a
similar training right like it's you're
not gonna produce that thing if you
listen to everyone as they just have
heard Casey Neistat say something very
similar about why he chose the path that
he did yeah right and this point is left
the barriers to bringing out your own
vision I have never been lower Yeah
right
exactly Anna the industry is not Sun
yeah you know anyway yeah the Internet
is is both the reason why this thing
spread but it's also they're gonna be
the thing that kills it yeah it's it's
it's too easy to talk so I so I mean
you're talking about solutions right
yeah my solution is very much just I
think it'll do its own work at people if
you can show people what it actually is
I have a it's a faith in that maybe
maybe I could be no no I think it's part
of it yeah I think there's another part
of it is what I was talking about they
need to see what it is they have to have
the ability to see what yeah everybody
rules you need to draw lines around it
so they can differentiate it from the
civil rights movements and the
intuitions that they have that are
correct I think maybe three things
necessary here believe it or not one is
okay the screen which we were decrying
at the beginning of this conversation is
the key to something else yeah you need
to see the canoe meeting on a screen
without somebody sitting there with you
judging you yeah right you need to be
able to just and just see it and
understand whoa that's a little that's a
little weird
yeah right - you need examples of people
who show you that you can resist this
right I resisted people swore I was a
conservative I swore I wasn't you know
what a couple years later people have
stopped telling me I'm a conservative
they've gotten it so the point is do you
have to join the Conservatives in order
to reject this stuff no and in fact
there's a way of just saying sorry
that's not where I yeah I'm friendly
with conservatives but I haven't joined
them because I still think we've
problems that need to be addressed yeah
yada yada yada but anyway human is a
helen pluck rose yeah anyone interested
in rosetta stone to be left-wing in this
current climate totally she's it oh
she's marvelous in so many different
ways but the so you need examples of
what it would look like to stand your
your philosophical ground in the face of
this you need the ability to see what it
looks like if you don't yeah right
who are you gonna be in that room are
you gonna be the people cheering the
canoe or you're gonna be the embarrassed
people you know participating because
they don't know what else to do and mind
you I should say in the defense of the
people who walked by me in that room
it's not a fair comparison because I was
a tenured professor yeah they were staff
I totally understand why you would jump
on yeah I I don't even know if I
wouldn't just jump on the canoe just to
just to not it's you know mean well
otherwise or something like that I'm not
I am like you in that I want to stand
against these things but I mean it makes
sense to her just jump on the back of
history but you know like his well it's
certainly better than losing your job
yeah and they hadn't had the information
that you had as well no they they had
but I mean again they were staff they
were vulnerable in a way that I actually
turned out to be vulnerable but but I
was a lot less vulnerable as a as
tenured faculty but in any case yeah I
don't so a in 2019 I don't think Mike
Dana jumps on that canoe because he has
I know the canoe meeting yeah yeah right
but okay so let's say that there are
three things going on here there's the
ability to with nobody pressuring you in
the room evaluate what this stuff
actually just objectively looks like on
your screen that's one thing there are
examples of what you can do other than
hop on the canoe and then there's the
sort of ideal you discussion layer which
is you know as you pointed out earlier
in this conversation there is a a large
population that are sort of interested
in this discussion just as there is a
large population looking for a movement
to solve the difficult problems of
existence yeah there's also a large
number of people looking for a
discussion that doesn't have this
mind-numbing characteristic yeah which
is why the IDW layer did so well is that
lots of people were feeling backed
against the wall and then suddenly they
were talking heads who didn't frankly
agree with each other on you know
politics but did agree with each other
on the fact that a this movement was a
problem and that be we needed to be
generous with each other and talk as a
whole in the market as well it's like we
let exploded because there's all this
stuff that the mainstream media and
hearts an entertainment weren't touching
and people want they want those things
so it's like there's this big market
force behind it as well that's why it
exploded they deal I mean yeah it's
seems so obvious now yeah obvious in
retrospect yeah yeah everything in
evolution is yeah so I guess the
interesting question as an American and
maybe maybe there's no such thing
anymore
yes sense that the entire world has a
powerful has a great deal at stake in an
American election yeah
and so anyway some of us are privileged
enough to have a vote in those elections
yeah but the question now is given our
electoral situation does that layer that
has bucked the trend actually survive to
the finals and so you know Tulsi Gabbard
and Andrew yang look very different to
me than the rest of the field yeah they
even look different than Bernie Sanders
who is the guy I supported all the way
to the end last election last
presidential election but okay so let's
let's figure out how to bring in a
couple of threads here but can we wrap
this up young one I want to talk to you
about how things look different to an
Australian to I want to talk to you
about
race and your own background and how you
see race generally how you see race
unfolding in in America yeah
so let's let's start there I'm scared to
talk about race in America because this
is a different it's a different thing
but well tell me that what do you want
me to stop doing I want you to start
right there
what so Americans in general don't know
that much about how the American context
is different yes the American context is
so dominant yes so many spheres it sort
of waves the water elysium everything is
Australians of looking at it through
your lens inside our scholarship so this
is weird crossover we had a black lives
matter parade at home and it's like
there's issues between the police and
Aboriginal communities yeah yeah there
is that but it's not it's not the same
thing like we have videos go viral
because police don't shoot it's like
this guy with a knife and then all the
Americans are sharing going why the hell
hasn't this guy shot it's just we don't
have the same problems as you guys so my
personal experience at the race I'm
mixed-race so my dad's Mershon African
Ireland my mum's Dutch blond hair blue
eyes so they're very very different so
race was nothing to me inside my
household yeah and like absolutely
nothing like you can't even see it
this is like different power dynamics
enough nothing has anything to do with
race and then a full race to become
something had to leave the home and so
it was this weird experience of race
being something very sensitive and
touchy and I don't I don't actually have
the inputs to give a [ __ ] about that
kind of stuff
I remember in primary school someone
said something racist to me and the room
went oh and in my mind I was like oh you
know this means I can do whatever I want
with this guy no way I win yeah I can
punch him in the teacher won't even get
angry at me
and so I did
but yeah so it's it's always been a like
a bit of a tool yeah it seems to me
because I've never actually felt it and
I've experienced I think Australia is
really good I think it's excellent for
first generations there's no issues
there's been some weird joking about
race with because I grew up in the
suburbs the blue-collar people and
there's a lot of jokes around race but I
always thought it was a kind of
inclusive racism you know way because
the jokes weren't dissimilar to the fat
kid or the kid with red hair or you
don't have just feeling it out there's a
taking the piss out of each other
dynamic yeah that is a little
uncomfortable to describe it really is
actually kind of a normal part of being
human and it includes all kinds of stuff
yeah and the racial element of it was
just you have to get someone where you
think it might be an Australian thing
yep you get someone where you think
they'll be sensitive right and then if
you let them play with that then that's
intimacy yeah and so to block that off I
don't know how I would have fit in
I wouldn't think I would have fit in
very well totally so it was very
multicultural place I grew up in it
always seemed like at all like I think
the first time I actually felt that
hanging out with in the arts and
entertainment with with the progressives
yeah because it's very much insert Brown
man here or we've got this thing and
you're you're a difference like we can
use you because of that and it was and
that they were all very they were too
sensitive around it like what is this
magical creature from another land and
and and that felt like it was an
authoring it was like an authoring of
inclusion and mothering of oh man hang
out with the guys call me a black prick
like they're they're they're less racist
than you guys in some sense and so yeah
it's it's been a strange strange journey
around the race stuff for me because I
don't feel it but also put my foot in
things they can I know that the history
here is a lot more sensitive than I
think it is back home I don't want to
definitely don't want to step on the
probe
within the aboriginal communities and
what the MMI country did to the first
people but I do think we're matters
Australia is really really really good
so we had a white Australia policy in
the 70s and that got abolished where was
just like only people who were allowed
to come in more white so that's an
explicit racism right yeah they
abolished that and then they wanted so
that was Simpson Baalak we don't want to
be racist anymore and so and so they did
that my dad who came from a country who
would imploded because of the English
moved out and then there was racial
tensions and so it was actually like
hardcore racism that was going on there
yeah like legitimate and he couldn't
advance because he was Creole you know
like African blood they weren't being
treated very well and so mixed blood
he comes to Australia and he so
Australia was still kind of racist when
he was there like he was they still had
that cultural stuff he had to work
through but he did a lot of work to work
work through that and gain advancement
to where we are now and to speak as
though the people who were black now are
going through the same struggles that he
went through in the 70s and after doing
all that work it's actually disgusting
to me
yes it's belittling all the hard work he
did Australia said we don't want to be
racist guys like my dad came and worked
at into the culture with with with grit
and sweat and and we're in such a good
place like my and he's advanced like
this this social mobility now sin he was
living in a bed with his a disabled
brother when he moved here fast forward
yeah quite a few 50 60 years and he's
managed through the course of my life
even we were poor when when we started
and now he's a wealthy man and it is so
it got to zero that out in order to to
reinvigorate Iran it convinced me that
this is a horrible place and racism is
everywhere yeah it is but not it's not
in my
we have made progress yes a lot yeah and
you you're talking about Australia I
think in general in the West yeah you've
made a great deal of progress yeah we're
so against racism in fact that if
someone is filmed sang erases comment
there of life is ruined
yeah and like why that's what's progress
life is actually good yeah it's a huge
progress yeah to pretend we're living in
the 50s and there's always kind of poor
me and my blackness and [ __ ] off like
it's not it's not the side of the world
so there are two points I want to pick
up from that one of them has to do with
something that you and I have talked
about which is that you know I can't say
for sure most of our minds are not
accessible to the conscious part but I
don't feel like I wake up a white guy
yeah I know that I'm a white guy it has
impacts but it's not the way I approach
my own life it's not the way I approach
other people and there's a kind of
camaraderie every time I meet somebody
who can say the same thing about their
origin there's a kind of meeting and I
want it defined so that people can join
it voluntarily right it's sort of like
human first yeah right I am a white
you've read of awning universalism which
is something that we had to write years
ago we had it well and I think the thing
is it's always it has since the civil
rights movement in this country it has
been the proper aspiration that sit
that's the one we if we can find a way
to tell people that this critical race
series are operating in the same sphere
as the white nationalists yeah are the
same people they just think that the
rewards should go into the different
teams yeah exactly if we can let people
understand that then they they currently
occupy some moral high ground right they
don't and they they have not earned they
it's horrific when you look at it and so
this this is something and this is why
you Martin Luther King gets brought up a
lot because it's right because it's
contentious because we all like the
Martin Luther King story and so it has
to
attacked for being somehow you know
ill-conceived or failed or something
like that which it isn't so the the
thing that you know you sometimes hear
religious people talking about their
faith yeah and for those of us I don't
know where you stand but for me I'm not
a person of faith and I can't quite
relate to the the emotional power that
they report yeah for having embraced
this yeah but I feel something like what
they describe in the space of people who
and I'm gonna be very careful about this
don't give a [ __ ] about race okay don't
give a [ __ ] about race does not mean
that you don't see it yeah colorblind is
something the civilization has to be yes
it has to be it doesn't mean that it
can't see that you have a racial
background and doesn't care about it to
the extent it's important it means that
when you come into a court your race
can't matter when you walk into a
classroom your race cannot matter you
can it come up at some point if it's
relevant to a discussion yes but your
teacher can't see you that yeah yeah so
the thing that I want to convey about it
is that I think I think it is true that
people who have made this step to human
first experience a huge leap in the
quality of their life that this is like
a raise you can give yourself mmm that
at the point that you abandon suspicions
of people based on their race yeah it is
a huge weight off your vendors and
walking down the street is a better
experience this is a scary thing like
I've been talking to a lot of a lot of
white men those evil white men and a lot
of them are reporting these strange
things like I see a an experience with a
black person then having to think how to
calculate too much too much yeah that's
it's so horrible to me cuz that's that's
like racism it's kind of reforming out
of this thing that's a it's like it's
RiRi and
virgins have rights like just don't
think about it's alright I totally agree
with its the breakdown of something that
wasn't perfect yes definitely work yeah
it wasn't perfect but but it was better
well let's take here's my favorite
example of this the n-word yeah for
decades in this country we had an
agreement
largely unspoken yeah but an agreement
why people didn't use the n-word black
people were free to I think that was the
right arrangement it is not the right
arrangement at the point that it can be
prosecuted especially if it is
prosecuted by the simple fact of having
uttered the sum yeah not even no intent
behind it right there are lots of
reasons to use the n-word if you had a
white person yeah let's suppose you're
you know in a production of Huck Finn
yeah right yeah you might have to say it
yeah right
suppose you're referring to you know
suppose I mean we're now in a problem
where hip-hop invokes analogues of the
n-word yeah sometimes the n-word itself
and white people aren't apparently
allowed to sing it and then that's what
is the the other one someone recently
was doing a using a I think they built
to do a discourse analysis yeah now
we're actually trying to map who was
actually racist in the OLT right area
and by mapping a lot of the the output
and so obviously the n-word is gonna be
a big indicator there but they weren't
allowed to present their present their
findings yeah no actually doing some
scholarly work you might have to say it
so anyway we had a gentlemen's agreement
to compromise a term but we had a
gentlemen's agreement that worked
I don't remember people in my circle
ever violating it in earnest yeah right
but it had to be predicated on the
discretion that actually yes this white
person did use the n-word but they did
not do it with intent therefore can I
bring that back to this the the
the theology sure so what what they're
doing they're so durkheimian view of
religion is religions have something
sacred and that's that's not to be
touched right so the way that the way
that I see that this is has started in
this in this strange thing is that you
had the postmodernist
shake the etch-a-sketch of Western
civilization so it's like everything
could be false and who knows what what
is true all it is about is about power
and and and so on and so forth
but it's very destructive like they're
just they're just playing and ripping
things apart and making people question
why they believe these these these giant
narratives then all of a sudden you get
kimberlé crenshaw who has really she
said with what we need to do is we need
to map postmodern techniques on to
political action and in that she talks
about what do you keep how do you do
that because it's this it's this kind of
abstract thing it's it's where you were
currently living in the void the edges
get straight is a blank page and she
said we do that by keeping oppression
based on race so she actually did the
Descartes thing I'm oppressed therefore
I am that's all that there is that's all
that there is yeah she said that
oppression is the thing we can keep and
we can build everything else around
oppression so that's that's the sacred
thing and that's that so it's oppression
its victimhood and that's where
victimhood culture comes from there's
this this is 30 years of scholarship on
top of this this one thing where
oppression based on identity is the only
thing that's real and if you speak to
these people you'll you'll find that
that's the only thing that they they
hold sacred and they keep steady that's
fascinating yeah so I will just say to
my audience that I think what you have
just unleashed here is a absolutely key
insight and it has to do with the
meaning of what sacred is and that if
you miss apply the
the normal stuff that goes along with
the sacred and you apply it to
oppression mm-hmm
then you create a situation where as you
approach the asymptotes of a world in
which people are judged on the content
of their character rather than the color
of their skin you have to work backwards
because you can't bear for the thing at
the core to evaporate yeah and that
explains what Douglas Murray has pointed
out about the tendency of these
movements that fight oppression to keep
going even after they've gotten to the
station yeah so anyway yeah that's a
that's a key piece of another podcast
it's a whole nother film yeah yeah I
think so
let me go back and clean up a lot of
thing civilization has to aim towards
colorblindness mmm individuals have to I
won't say have to but I think they would
be wise every single individual would be
wise to check in with the idea of being
human first and shedding all of the cost
that they pay out of whatever bigotries
and suspicions they might Harbor but
this does not mean that anybody's
ethnicity or background can be or should
be erased and I wanted to tell a little
story in light of what you were saying
about people joking about race oh yeah
fat kid and all that I'm gonna shield
the identities here because because I
think I have to and what yeah that's not
really why and in fact I think everybody
involved in the story would be cool with
it but I just I'm not so sure that I'm
ready to take the risk on their behalf
somebody well-known very well-known oh
that's the reason okay in the IDW sphere
he invited Heather and me to a dinner
party an intimate dinner party at this
person's house and there were guests
there
that she clearly had carefully chosen
who would be a good person to to be at
the dinner and a woman at the party told
a joke at the dinner table and the joke
was do you know what the definition of
anti-semitism is and I said no I don't
she says it's hating Jews more than is
necessary right and I must say that joke
could be taken very negatively yeah
but the context of that joke it was
delivered in full knowledge of what
table she was at yeah who she was
talking to yeah and it felt very
welcoming that this joke actually point
what there's some natural tension around
Jews yeah right yeah and that's released
right it it's your say the point is joke
was an embrace and it was complex yeah
it's hard to even report it so it
doesn't cause people to say how long
right but the point is but the feelings
in the room is she knew what shall
circumstellar yes she knew how right and
so anyway you can't write the rule no I
challenge you to write the rule that
explains why that joke is okay yeah
right that joke is okay because of
something really deep inside that
understands how it will be heard on the
other side right as is the nature of
jokes yeah it is both the key to their
being biting yeah and the key to their
being generous and so you can't write
the rule it's unraidable yeah right so
in a world where things as important as
jokes yes have to abide by rules that
cannot possibly be written yeah we have
to be generous right
I saw Trevor Noah
on a podcast discussing this n-word
question about
you know his position was very clear
white people do not get to sing the
n-word when it's in a song you know a
hip-hop song yeah everybody has the
ability to edit you don't have an excuse
now my feeling is we had an agreement
yeah greement is now broken down because
you're now entering things into our
common culture that require you can't
enter things into our common culture
that we don't all have the right to
equally participate in I don't have any
need to say the N word yeah I don't have
any need for it but you know what if I'm
gonna sing hurricane yeah the Bob Dylan
song it's in there I'm singing it right
now in that case Bob Dylan is why does
that you know you can't write the guy
the calculations that are going on here
around something that can we we're all
adults
okay can you can tell you know when it's
when it's happening out of you know when
it's being said in earnest yes unless
you're looking for paper unless you're
looking for discourses right right
unless you're looking for power next
case you can use yeah gray area case and
yeah but it's not yeah they call them
bodies they don't matter well and you
know they in some sense what I'm talking
about with respect to lineage reflects
this truth is that we are simultaneously
individuals and participants in
something very real biological and
larger just the same way your cells are
actual cells that actually have to
function but they're also part of
something larger so yeah these
discourses as it were have a functional
implication and the hazard of them is
spectacular well you have any final
thoughts you want to know I think we
covered a lot we did cover a lot yet all
right well this was excellent Mike
really appreciate your voice where
should people look for you Mike Nina
Twitter YouTube preferably YouTube
YouTube has got a lot of its got the
series we were talking about and some
other work that I'm just uploading as I
work on a feature-length film so I'm
just putting off cuts and so other bits
and pieces on YouTube Mike Nina's
YouTube channel
yeah among other things you can find
pieces of the grievance studies yeah
work you haven't completed the larger
thing yet but there are very interesting
pieces there you can find the Evergreen
three-part evergreen documentary if
canoe meeting is a head-scratcher for
you you might check in with Atmos fly
some of it yeah you're on Twitter yep
your handle is Mike Nanna my name why na
na ey na alright and for my part you can
sign up for my YouTube channel if you
haven't subscribed yet that's always
helpful if you do it you can find me on
twitter at brett weinstein you can find
me on patreon and i certainly appreciate
you all tuning in
[Music]